it is a very ambitious script and we
wanted to do so much in so little time
and we really set the bar high so to do
a job like this and really test the
camera and test what you can do it's
just fantastic so of course we have to
do it it's a big camera so it needs to
fit but I think we've been you know
designing the sets in exactly the way we
want them getting experience you know of
this kind of format in this kind of
shooting it's difficult to go back
slow 10% down the pace we start you know
in this limited frame and then we open
up that little frame within the frame is
regular format that was really neat from
then when you passed that frame that's
the change you go from one world to
another from wheel to unreal
that's the feeling I get when you look
through the camera three
okay cut back the wall the screen is so
big and you really want to create an
immersive experience just a boy sir
and then or just gonna fall or chicken
just move a little bit let's just go
feeling about canvas and button
spherical elements to make us rich and
intriguing as possible there's a lot of
pulse involved in this film but I have
to say I think it's really fun let me
get it in camera because it's instant
gratification
it's all is so important because it
makes the world surround you truly
enhanced experience
[Applause]
what you move is in la max is just a
greatest experience there is it's magic
you know it will take you somewhere else
that will transport you to different
worlds an IMAX is the best place to
experience that
you